SCORCHING NEARLY 30,000 ACRES
BLAMED FOR AT LEFT ONE DEATH.
>> THIS IS NOT CONVENTIONAL
HYPOCRISY.
THIS IS LET’S STOP LYING, AN
ACT OF HOSTILITY AGAINST THE
POPULATION OF THE COUNTRY.
THEY DESPISE YOU, THEY ARE
FLAUNTING IT.
THIS IS HOW PEOPLE WHO DON’T
LIKE YOU BEHAVE.
THEY FORCE YOU TO DO ONE THING,
THEY DO ANOTHER, THEY GET
CAUGHT.
THEY AREN’T EMBARRASSED AND
KEEP FORCING TO YOU DO THE
THING THEY’RE NOT DOING.
>> TRACE: TUCKER CARLSON
RIPPING INTO POLITICIANS WHO
DON’T FOLLOW THEIR OWN
CORONAVIRUS RESTRICTIONS LIKE
GOVERNOR NEWSOM CAUGHT AT A
BIRTHDAY PARTY NOT WEARING A
MASK AND NOT SOCIALLY DISTANCED.
NOT THE ONLY ELECTED OFFICIAL
BENDING THE RULES.
PHILADELPHIA MAYOR JIM KENNY
WAS SEEN AT A BAR BEFORE
ANNOUNCING A BAN ON ALL INDOOR
DINING.
D.C. MAYOR BROWSER TRAVELED TO
DELAWARE TO ATTEND JOE BIDEN’S
VICTORY SPEECH IGNORING HER OWN
TRAVEL RESTRICTIONS.
SHE SAYS IT WAS ESSENTIAL
TRAVEL.
CHICAGO MAYOR LORI LIGHT FOOT
ATTENDED A MASSIVE STREET PARTY
AFTER SHE ANNOUNCED A STAY AT
HOME ADVISORY FOR THE ENTIRE
CITY.
WITH US NOW GOVERNOR MIKE
HUCKABEE.
ALWAYS GOOD TO SEE YOU.
THE REASON THIS GAVIN NEWSOM
THING IS GETTING SO MUCH
ATTENTION.
HE DIDN’T JUST BREAK THE RULES,
HE BLEW UP THE RULES.
WE MENTIONED IT WAS A LARGE
GATHERING, MORE THAN A DOZEN
PEOPLE.
NO SOCIAL DISTANCING, NO MASKS
AND THEY SAID IT WAS OUTDOORS
BUT ACTUALLY INDOORS BECAUSE
THEY HAD TO CLOSE THE SLIDING
GLASS DOORS BECAUSE IT WAS SO
LOUD AND THE CDC REPEATEDLY
SAYS LOUD EVENTS WHERE ALL YOU
HAVE THE DROPLETS ARE COMING
OUT OF YOUR MOUTH CAN BE SUPER
SPREADER EVENTS, THIS THING
BROKE EVERY RULE YOU CAN HAVE.
>> I THINK YOU ARE BEING A
LITTLE HARSH ON HIM TRACE.
HE DIDN’T SING OR CHANT OR
DIDN’T WORSHIP.
THOSE THINGS WOULD HAVE BEEN
DANGEROUS.
SIMPLY GOING AND NOT WEARING A
MAX AND YELLING WITH HIS
FRIENDS, THAT’S OKAY.
LOOK, HE IS PHONEIER THAN A
VEGAN AT A STEAKHOUSE AND
PROVED IT.
THAT VIDEO JUST UNDID HIM.
THERE IS A FIX TO ALL THIS
WHETHER IT’S LORI LIGHTFOOT OR
NEWSOM OR THE MAYOR OF D.C.
SIMPLE FIX.
IF YOU ARE A GOVERNMENT
OFFICIAL AND YOU SHUT OTHER
PEOPLE’S BUSINESSES DOWN, YOU
DON’T GET PAID.
IF THEY LOSE THEIR PAYCHECK AND
YOU ARE THE ONE RESPONSIBLE,
YOU DON’T GET YOUR PAYCHECK.
LET’S SEE HOW THAT GOES.
I’M NOT BEING FACETIOUS ABOUT
IT.
THERE IS NO SKIN IN THE GAME OF
THESE GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS.
THEY ARE MAKING BIG DECISIONS
ABOUT THE PEASANTS LIKE US WHO
HAVE TO LIVE BY THE RULES.
THEY DON’T LIVE BY THEM AND
THEY HAVE NO CONSEQUENCE.
THEY DON’T LOSE A DIME OF THEIR
SALARY.
THEY GET TAXPAYER MONEY AND IT
NEVER GOES AWAY.
LET IT GO AWAY AND LET THEM
SUFFER CONSEQUENCES FINANCIALLY
AND YOU’LL SEE THIS CHANGE.
>> TRACE: YOU TALK ABOUT
PEASANTS.
CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE WOMAN
REPUBLICAN SAYING EATING WITH A
BUNCH OF LOBBYISTS AT AN
EXPENSIVE RESTAURANTS AT THE
SAME TIME YOU PUT HALF OF
CALIFORNIA OUT OF WORK.
ADD UP DRINKS AND APPETIZERS,
THEIR MEAL PER PERSON WAS MORE
THAN THE MONTHLY UNEMPLOYMENT
CHECK.
OF COURSE, PEOPLE DON’T KNOW
THE FRENCH LAUNDRY AVERAGE TAB
ABOUT $1,000.
>> YEAH, THIS IS NOT A PLACE
WHERE PEOPLE GET THEIR CLOTHES
CLEANED.
THEIR WALLETS ARE CLEANED OUT
BECAUSE IT IS THAT EXPENSIVE.
THE AVERAGE MINIMUM DINING
EXPERIENCE IS $350 PER PERSON.
MINIMUM.
THINK ABOUT HOW MANY PEOPLE
COULD EVEN CONCEIVE OF SPENDING
THAT FOR A MEAL.
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATORS GOING TO
HAWAII.
THIS IS HYPOCRISY.
THEY NEED TO READ AND FIND WHAT
HAP WHENS THE PEASANTS GET IT
UP TO HEAR WITH THAT KIND OF
STUFF.
>> TRACE: YOU GET WATER AND A
TOOTHPICK FOR $350.
THE LAWMAKERS GOING TO HAWAII.
PUT THIS ON THE SCREEN.
YOU HAVE THESE EXCUSES, RIGHT?
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JORDAN
CUNNINGHAM ON THE TRIP TO
HAWAII SAID THE FOLLOWING.
IN THIS EVENT PROMOTES
INTELLIGENT PUBLIC POLICY IN
OUR STATE.
WE’RE HERE DISCUSSING WAYS WE
CAN SAFELY REOPEN OUR SOCIETY.
AND SAVE OUR SMALL BUSINESSES,
WORKERS AND KIDS.
NO BETTER PLACE TO WORK ON
CORONAVIRUS THAN THE FAIRMONT
WAIALAE.
IT’S AMAZING.
ONE SAYS THE TRIP WAS ESSENTIAL.
WELL, THE RESTAURANT WASN’T IN
PENNSYLVANIA PROPER.
THE EXCUSES ARE ALMOST AS
ANNOYING AS THE ACTUAL ACTS
THEMSELVES.
YOUR FINAL THOUGHTS.
>> THEY TRULY ARE.
TO BE IN AN AIRPLANE FOR EIGHT
HOURS IN A SMALL ALUMINUM TUBE.
THAT’S PERFECTLY SAFE.
TO GET TO HAWAII, THAT’S FINE.
I’M SURE ALL THE LITTLE PEOPLE,
ALL THE LITTLE PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND HOW VALUABLE IT WAS
TO THEM FOR THEIR PUBLIC
OFFICIALS ON THE TAXPAYERS’
DIME TO GO TO HAWAII AND BACK
WHEN THEY CAN’T EVEN GO TO
CHURCH OR GO AND HAVE
THANKSGIVING WITH THEIR OWN
FAMILIES.
SURE, THAT MAKES SENSE.
>> TRACE: GOVERNOR MIKE